[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى هذه الصور من العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن التي تعيش على واقع
اعلاني وزاره العدل تعيين محققا خاصا
لتحقيق في ملف الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ
بها الرئيس الامريكي
البيت الابيض
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
اردوغان يحضر في اتصالين منفصلين مع
الرئيسين الروسي والاوكراني من مخاطر
اطانه امد الحرب ويؤكد ان اجتماعات
مسؤوليه الاستخبارات الروس والامريكيين
تلعب دورا من رئيسا في منع التسعيدي في
الميدان
الترم لان يقول ان الحوار مع الغرب يمكن
ان يصبح عنصرا قويا في المفاوضات بين
روسيا واوكرانيا وسنسكي يقول انه اكد
لاردوغان التعاون في مجالي الامن والطاقه
ويؤكد ان اوكرانيا ستبقى ضامنه للامن
الغذائي
تسرب نورد ستريم والقول الفصل السويد تعلن
ان التحقيق خلص الى العثور على مواد
متفجره قرب خطي الانابيب بعد تسرب الذي
وقع في سبتمبر الماضي الكريملين يرحب
بخلاصه التحقيقات ويقول انها تدعم صدقيه
المعلومات الروسيه ويدعو الى تحديد الجهه
المسؤوله عن الهجوم
كوريا الشماليه والمزيد من تجارب الصواريخ
البالستيه
رغم التحضيرات الامريكيه بيونديان تطلق
صاروخا عابرا للقارات واشنطن تجري مناورات
عسكريه مع اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه تحاكي
استهداف قاذفات صواريخ ليبياغان والصين
تدعو الاطراف الى الالتزام بالسعي لتسويه
سياسيه
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه نقشنا معكم بدء مغادره المئه من
موظفي شركه بيتر لهذه الشركه بعد انداري
مالكها الجديد الى مصر بان على الموظفين
الراغبين في البقاء العمل لساعات طويله
وبكثافه عاليه ياتي هذا ضمن سلسله من
الاحداث المتلاحقه مؤخرا عززات المخاوف من
تاثر المنصه التقنيه وايضا من تاثر
المعايير والسياسات العامه
قد طرحنا عليكم قبل قليل السؤال التالي
الذي يقول هل تهدد التطورات الاخيره وجوده
منصه تويتر
قالوا انها فعلا تهدد وجود هذه المنصه بين
المراه سبعه وعشرون بالمئه انها لا تهدد
وجودها
في حين يرجح 25% ان منصه تويتر ستتاثر
جزئيا في المحتوى وكذلك في الجانب
التقليدي
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا في منصات
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره حاليا على الشاشه
لقائنا
يتجدد يوميا و نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد ايضا
كاس العالم في قطر ساعات قليله على
الانطلاق وقراءه في التجربه
[موسيقى]
انا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اجراء
مباحثات هاتفيه منفصله مع كل من الرئيس
الروسي
والرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ميرسي لينسكي ضمن
المساعد دبلوماسيه لانهاء الحرب هذا وقد
قال متحدث باسم الكريملين واردوغان اكد
اهميه التنفيذ الشامل والكامل لصفقه
الحبوب من جهه قال زي الناس كان هناك شمع
اردوغان التعاون في مجال الطاقه والامن
مؤكدا ان بلاده ستبقى ضامنه للامن الغذائي
في العالم
يوما بعد يوم تتجدد كل الاسئله الحائره
المتعلقه بمالات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وقد مرت تسعه اشهر على اندلاعها
تبرز المساعد دبلوماسيه التركيه في هذا
الصدد الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بحث هاتفيا
مع نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
والاوكراني فلودي ميرسي لنسكي القضايا ذات
الصله بالحرب ملونا لضروره احياء
المحادثات الدبلوماسيه ومحذرا مما سماعه
الجوارب السلبيه لاطاله امد الحرب
ويظنك ان اضواء خافته في محيط الازمه ظهرت
مع تمديد اتفاق الحبوب في البحر الاسود
قبل يومين لمده اربعه اشهر والذي تم
توقيعه في يوليو الماضي برعايه الامم
المتحده وجهود تركيه مباشره وغير مباشره
ولا طالما عبر الرئيس التركي منذ لقائه
بنظره الاوكراني والامين العام للامم
المتحده
انطونيو غوتيرش في مدينه الفيف غربي
اوكرانيا عن ضروره الاستفاده من المناخ
الايجابي الذي يوفره اتفاق الحبوب للبحث
عن سبل التوسل لانهاء الحرب
ووجه الرئيس اردوغان الانظار صوبا لقاءات
الاخيره التي استضافتها بلاده بين مسؤول
المخابرات الروسيه والامريكيه وتعول على
استمرارها على الاقل لتقريب المواقف
المتباعده جدا حتى الان روسيا رفضت على
لسان نائب وزير
الافصاح عن تفاصيل ذلك الاجتماع
الاستخبارات الذي تم في تركيا لكن رياض
كهوف لم يستبعد اجراء اتصالاتنا على مستوى
اعلى اذا ما ابدى الامريكيون الرغبه في
ذلك ويعتبر الكريملين ان الحوار مع الغرب
عنصر مهم وقوي في اي مفاوضات مع اوكرانيا
ويقول انك تنفذ توجيهات الغرب
بدقه
واشنطن على ان خيار التفاوض ووقته قرار
اوكراني وكييف قليله الحديث في هذا الصدب
الرئيس ظل نسكي يرحب بالوساطه التركيه
لكنه يكرر كثيرا اهميه وضع حد لما يصفه
بالاستفزازات الروسيه وسياسه التدبير
المنهج الذي تنفذها روسيا في بلاده واكتفى
في اتصال الجمعه مع اردوغان على تاكيد
ضمان بلاده للامن الغذائي العالمي نعم
هناك جهود تركيه مبذوله تجد الدعم ولو على
استحياء من الولايات المتحده ولكن من
السابق للاوائل الجزوي امكانيه اجراء
مفاوضات سلسه تعين على انهاء حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا
ويضم الينا من انقره بلجي خان اوسترك
المحلل السياسي في مركز سيتا للابحاث اهلا
بك اي افق من حقيقي لهذا التحرك التركي
وفي نفس الوقت من بين الرئيس الرئيس
اردوغان قادر على التكلم الى الطرفين
وبشكل متماشي ومستمر هو يحاول بدل افضل
الجهوده من اجل اقناع طرفين لكي يحل
المشاكل بينهما لحد الان المشاكل كانت
تتعلق باتفاق الحبوب وتبادل الاسرى لكن
اعتقد هذه المره بالتاكيد فان مساله
استئناف وتمديد اتفاق الحبوب كان على قمه
اولويات في نفس الوقت اعتقد هذه المره
ايضا بوجود تطورات
وال الاجتماع حاول
ان يقنع فوتا وزن سكي في ان يصل الى وقت
لاطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
ليس فقط محاوله اقناع الطرفين لكي يقومون
فقط بتمديد اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب لانه
الان هنالك تطورت قد
جئت
تخلق جوا لوقفا لاطلاق النار احدهما هو
سوء اداء القوات الروسيه وايضا والانسحاب
من خرسان وهنالك ايضا مؤشرات مؤخرا اتت من
الولايات المتحده نحو اتجاهها انه على
الرغبه بان جانب الامريكي قد لا قد يفضل
يوقف الاطلاق النار لان الان لانه هنالك
مؤشرات منها
ان هذه الحرب المستمره مقرفه للغايه
وهنالك خوف ايضا من التهديد من قبل الروس
ومديره الاستخبارات
المركزيه واجتماعهم في انقره اعتقدوا ان
هذا هذه المره كان يركز حول احتمالات
الوصول الى وقت لاطلاق النار بالاضافه الى
مناقشه التهديد النووي بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هل معنى ذلك
ان فرص اردوغان الان افضل من السابق
اوف كورس
عن هنالك بيئه مهيئه لوقف لاطلاق النار
منذ البدايه نعم فان انقر كانت تريد ان
تصل الى وقت لاطلاق النار لكن الامر كان
يتعدى سيطره اردوغان وانقر لانه بالرغم
التمتع بعلاقات نوديه مع كلاب فان تركيا
ليست في وضعا يمكنها من ان تفرض وقفا
لاطلاق النار على الطرفين كلا طرفين لن
يستمعا الى انقره الى هذا المدى لكن اذا
ما كانت هنالك ظروف مواتيه
فان تركيا ومبادراتها وجهودها قد تاتي
بثمارها هذه المره كما ذكرت في الجزء
الاول من اجابتي لان الولايات المتحده
الان نقول انها تعيد النظر وتعيد
النظر في موقفها الحرب في نفس الوقت هنالك
ادراك روسي انها لا يمكنها ان تستمر في
هذه الحرب هذا الاداء اعتقدوا ان الصوره
باكملها توحي وتقترح بامكانيه حصول الى
وقف التوصل الى وقف الاطلاق النار واعتقد
ان الرئيس اردوغان يريد ان يبني على هذا
الامر اعتقد انه بالاضافه الى مساله اقناع
الطرفين من المساله اتفاقي الحدود فان
اردوغان الى ان يحاول بشكل فعال ان يقنع
ترى
الى وقف لاطلاق النار بالتاكيد فان جانب
الروسي الان اكثر رغبه في تقبل مثل هذا
الامر لانهم يحتاجونه يحتاجونه من اجل
خسائره لكن في نفس الوقت على اوكرانيا ان
تكون مقتنعه
من انقره
قالت الخارجيه القطريه ان نائب رئيس
الوزراء والزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني اجر اتصال
هاتفيه مع مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيكسون وقال وزير الخارجيه القطري انه
ناقش مع سلفا عددا من القضايا الاقليميه
والدوليه لاسيه ما تداعيات الازمه بين
روسيا واوكرانيا وسبل حلها بطريقه سلميه
اعلنت روسيا تشيدها تحسينات جديده في شبه
جزيره القرم بعد نحو اسبوعا على انسحاب
جنودها من مدينه خرسون المجاوره اثر هجوم
مضاد من الجيش الاوكراني وقال سيرجي
الجزيره عام 2014 ان هذه الخطوه جاءت
لضمان سلامه سكان القرن لكنه شدد على ان
شبه الجزيره يتم بشكل رئيسي من خلال
الاجراءات التي ستنفذ على اراضي منطقه
خرسان وكان انسحاب الجنود الروس من مدينه
كرسون مركز المقاطعه التي تحمل اسم نفسه
قد سمح للقوات الاخرانيه بوضع اسلحتها في
مواقع اقرب الى شبه جزيره القرم التي
استهدفت عده مرات في الاشهر الاخيره
هذا وقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تنفيذ
تجربه ناجحه لمنظومه صواريخ سارمات
البالستيه العابره للقارات وقال نائب قائد
القوات الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
سيرجي برج كون ان الصاروخ البالستيه
الروسيه الجديد سيبقى في الخدمه لمده 50
عاما مقبلا مضيفا ان وقت الخدمه الطويل
المحدد لصاروخ صارمات يعود الى خصائصه
وموته العاليه وفق تعبير
[موسيقى]
بعد اكثر من سبعه اسابيع على حادثه تسرب
الغاز في بحر البلطيق تقدم السويد السويد
دليلا جديدا يؤكد فرضيه التخريب المتعمد
لخطي نورد ستريم
روسيا رغم انه لم يشرف باصبع الاتهام الى
طرف بعينه يمكن ان يكون وراء ذلك التخريب
تعود حادثه التسريب من خطي انابيب الغاز
الروسي النردسترين واحد ونور الدين اثنين
الى الواجهتين من جديد مع تاكيد المدعي
العام السويدي تعرضهما لعمل تخريبي متعمد
بعد العثور على اثار مواد متفجره قرب
الخطاين داخل المياه الاقليميه السويديه
في بحر البلطيق بحسب المدعي العام السويدي
فان هذه النتائج جاءت اثر تحقيق شامل
ومعقد للغايه استمر لاسابيع الاعلان
السويدينج مبديا ترحيبه بخلاصه تحقيقات
ستوكه معتبرون ان فرضيه الهجوم الارهابي
تؤكد مصداقيه المعلومات الروسيه داعيا الى
تحديد الجهه المسؤوله عن التفجير وسبق
للسلطات الدنماركيه ان صرحت الشهر الماضي
بان تحقيقاتها الاوليه اظهرت ان سبب
تسريبات في الخطين الذين كانال مصدر الاهم
لنقل الغاز الروسي الى اوروبا هو انفجارات
قويه حادثه التسريب كانت قد كشفت في
السادس والعشرين من سبتمبر الماضي بعد
انخفاض سريعا وغير متوقع للضغط في انابيب
الغاز المتوقفه عن العمل حينها منذ نهايه
اغسطس الماضي ليتبين لاحقا ظهور اربع
فجوات في خطين وردسترين واحد واثنين داخل
المياه الاقليميه لكل من السويد والدنمارك
تبادلت حينها كل من روسيا والدول الغربيه
الاتهامات بشان المسؤوليه عن التفجير في
حين يرجحت الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان يكون
غواصونا وضعوا عبوات متفجره على مسار
الانبوب موسكو التي وصفت انا ذاك
الاتهامات الغربيه الغربيه والسخيفه قالت
الشهر الماضي ان افرادا من البحريه
البريطانيه فجروا خطي الانابيب وهو اتهام
وصفته لندن بانه زائر
ويهدف الى صرف الانتباه عن الاخفاقات
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
جول الاكادي والمحلل السياسي كما ينضم
الينا من واشنطن السفير وليام كورتني
مساعد الرئيس كلينتون لشؤون روسيا
واوكرانيا والباحث في مؤسسه راند اهلا
بهما نبدا بضيفنا من موسكو على اي اساس
جاء هذا الترحيب الروسي بما اعلنه الادعاء
السويدي
نور وزني
استطيع
نرحب
المفاوضات
موجوده مع الشركاء الغربيين فقط في حاله
اذا كانوا سوف يستمعون لنا وينستون
لموقفنا واذا كان الحوار عن اوكراني سوف
يصل الى نقطه مغلقه
حديثنا عن حديثنا عن اعلنه الادعاء
السويدي من ان ما جرى مع خطين اردني ستريم
هو عمل تخريبي وموسكو رحبت بذلك فاسمح لي
سؤالي عن الترحيب الروسي
بمعلنه الادعاء السويدي على اي اساس
بالنسبه للسويد
موضوعيه وان تكون هذه التحقيقات على اساس
النظر الروسيه والمشاركه الروسيه
معنا والان بعد اعلان السويد
هذا ونرحب ان السويد مهتمه
بالتحقيقات
الموضوعيه هذا من نرحب به لذلك
الروسي يجب ان ينصت له وينسط لموقفه
يرحب بالخبراء الروس نحن نرحب بالتحقيقات
من اطراف
السويدي وان هذا فعلا عمل ارهابي ويجب ان
تسمي الامور على حقيقتها لكن الوصف بانه
ارهابي سفير ويليام كارني هل يعني
بالضروره بان الاتهام السابق
لموسكو سيسقط
صويلح
حقيقا حول هذا الانفجار ربما
فان الحكومه السويديه ستكون لديها شكوك ان
اي محققين سترسلهم روسيا لن يقوم بتوفير
معلومات
صادقه لان الحكومه الروسيه اعتادت ان لا
تقوم بتوفي معلومات صحيحه بشكل عام
بالتالي
اعتقد ان علينا ان
نتحلى بالصبر وننتظر الى انتهاء التحقيقات
[موسيقى]
بس قال اكثر التحقيق معقد وشامل للغايه
وعلينا ان ننتظر حتى نتعرف على اي مشتبهم
همم هل تعتقد بان هذا سيطول السفير ويلي
انا اعرف انا اتخيل ان الولايات المتحده
ستكون راغبه ان تقدم المساعده في تحليل
هذه المعلومات المتوفره لكن لا اعرف الى
اي مدى قد يستغرق هذا التحقيق
الدكتور
اتهمت البحريه البريطانيه على اي اساس
ايضا جرى هذا الاتهام اذا كانت موسكو
تعتبر انها مظلومه في اتهامها
نصوص توماس يوسف
الى ان بريطانيا فعلا مطورطه في هذه
الامور وكل هذه
الدلائل لن نظهرها الان لان هذه معلومات
سريه وهذا شيء مفهوم
اذا المخابرات اعلنت هذا اذا هناك دلا
الواضح ثم دعونا نسال سؤال منطقي لماذا
على روسيا ان تفجر ممتلكاتها في
النورسترين تعلمون ان بريطانيا والولايات
المتحده لم يكونوا يريدون ان تعمل هذه
الخطوط الاول ولا الثاني علما ان السيد في
شهر مارس انه سوف يدمر
يعلمون ان لدى روسيا كل الاسباب حتى تظن
او تدلل على ان القوات الخاصه او
المخابرات البريطانيه هي من
هذا العمل تخريبي والكثير من
المحللين السياسيين قالوا ان هذا ليس في
مصلحه روسيا
واذا قمنا
بالتحقيقات شريفه يجب ان نقول ان الجميع
يجب ان يحضروا في التحقيقات والشركاء
الاوروبيين لا يريدوا هذا اذا يريدون ان
يخفوا عنا بعض المعلومات
تقوم بتحقيق طلباتنا بوجودنا في التحقيقات
ونحن سعيدين بهذا ولكن يجب ان يسمح لنا
بالوصول الى هناك واذا كان هناك
اعمال سريه هناك الامور الواضحه روسيا لا
تعلن عن اي شيء من فراغ اذا قلنا ان هناك
اذا كانت روسيا تريد هذا التحقيق المشترك
هل معنى ذلك سفير ويليام كارني بان هذا
التحقيق المشترك هو الكفيل وحده باظهار
الحقيقه وانصاف الجميع
انا
قد يؤدي ربما الى نتائج
حقيقيه وصادقه من الصعب الثقه باي تحقيق
قد تجريه روسيا لاننا كما نرى نوع
التحقيقات التي تقوم بها روسيا
داخليا في روسيا ضد
معارضين للحكومه هذه تلك التحقيقات هي
غالبا تكون تحقيقات غير حقيقيه لذلك كما
راينا في حالتي
في مصر
الركام من بقايا
الصاروخ الاوكراني فان الحكومات الغربيه
لديها سجله سجل حافل باجرائي تحقيقات
حقيقيه ومستقله وبالتالي توصلت نتيجه
التحقيق الذي اجروها على ان هذا الصاروخ
لم يكن صاروخ روسيه في تلك الحديثه
الدكتور
[موسيقى]
كوريا الجنوبيه ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت
ما يبدو انه صاروخ بالستي عابر للقارات
وقال مسؤولون يابانيون ان الصاروخ سقط في
البحر على بعد 200 متر فقط من اليابان
وياتي اطلاق الصاروخ الجديد بعد يوم واحد
فقط من اطلاق كوريا الشماليه صاروخا
باليستيا قصيره المدى احتجاجا على الاتفاق
بين كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
واليابان على تعزيز التحالف الامني ورده
على التجربه الصاروخيه لكوريا اعلن الجيش
الكوريه الجنوبي تحليقه مقاتلات كوريه
جنوبيه من طراز اف 35 اي وطائرات امريكيه
من طراز اف 16 في تشكيل جوي قباله الساحل
الشرقي لشبه جزيره الكوريه كما اجر الجيش
الكوري الجنوبي تدريبات على اطلاق النار
ضد اهداف تحاكي قد فات الصواريخ المحموله
لكوريا واجره القوات الامريكيه واليابانيه
مناورات مماثله
هذا وقد اعلنت الخارجيه الصينيه النبيين
تتابع عن كتب التطورات في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه معربه عن املها في ان تسعى
الاطراف الى تسويه سياسيه تعالج مخاوف كل
طرف بطريقه متوازنه من خلال الحوار
واقله الخارجيه الصينيه ان منع التصعيد في
شبه الجزيره الكوريه يسب في مصلحه المجتمع
الدولي باسره
العلاقات الدوليه في جماعه الدراسات
الدوليه في روما والخبير في الشؤون
الاسيويه اهلا وسهلا بك
بتقديرك الى متى سيستمر هذا
المشهد في التكرار بنفس التعابير تقريبا
بين كوريا الشماليه وكوريا الجنوبيه
المسانده من قبل الغرب
[موسيقى]
طالما
شعره كوريا الشماليه بتهديد
الاسلحه النوويه هي ضامن لنظام كيم جون
اون الذي يخشى ان
يقوم قد يقضى عليه اذا ما لم يطور الاسلحه
النوويه هذه هو السبب الحقيقي الذي
يدعونا لرؤيته كوريا الشماليه وهي تناضل
من اجل ان تحصل على امكانيات النوويه
فعاله
بعد يومين فقط من تحذيرها عن على تجربه
سابقه هذا التحدي الكوري الشمالي
هل له مستقبل
يعويلكم
اذا ما كنا نتحدث عن التدريبات العسكريه
عمليات اطلاق صواريخ واختبارات الصاروخيه
الاستراتيجيه ستستمر خاصه في سياق هذه
الامور في سياقها والسياق التي تاتي فيه
هنالك
منافس منافسه مستمره بين
اداره من جانب هنالك شراك مستمره قد
تهدد النظام
من جهه اخرى هنالك شيء اخر كم يخشاه وهو
التقارب بين جو بارد
منشن
ذكره وكان هو المثال الاول
للتقارب الدبلوماسيه بين الولايات المتحده
والصين وهذا هو الشيء الذي يخشى رئيس
كوريا الشماليه لان هذا الامر يعني بان
الصين بامكانها ان تخنق كوريا الشماليه
بمحادثات نوويه وعقوبات بالتالي هذه هي
المؤشرات التي يحاول ان يرسلها فيما يتعلق
بالتقارب بين جو بارد
مستعده للحوار مع كوريا الشماليه وفي نفس
الوقت تهددها بامكانيه همم اشياء
خطيره عسكريه هل يمكن ان ينجح هذا التوجه
مع بيونغيانغ
اعتقد
حاليا يشعر بعدم الاستقرار لسبب واحد انه
لا يريد ان يكون
تريد ان يريد ان يشعر بالاطمئنان والضمان
الوحيد له هو وجود السلاح النووي ايضا
مساله وجود روسيا الى جانبها وليس بالظام
لان روسيا الان تزداد عزله في المجتمع
الدولي الضامن الوحيد لنجاه قريه شماليه
ونظامها هي الصيد لكن الصين الان حاليا لا
يمكنها ان تكون الضامن سياسي الافضل
لكوريا الشماليه لان الصين نفسها هي تحاول
ان تتاقلمه مع عدم الاستقرار الدولي
وتحاول ان تبحث عن
ربما شاركت مقربه مع الولايات المتحده هذا
ما اتى بعده محادثات همم قمه العشرين وقمه
الاشياء بالتالي فان بيونغ هي تقوم الان
بهذه الاختبارات الصاروخيه لارسال رساله
لانها موجوده وانها ستستمر والبقاء
شكرا لك الوينزو تيرمن من روما
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير
انطوني بلنكن سيزور الدوحه يومي الحادي
والعشرين والثاني والعشرين من نوفمبر
الجاري لاطلاق الحوار الاستراتيجي السنوي
الخامس بين الولايات المتحده وقطر وقالت
الخارجيه الامريكيه
سيعرب للمسؤولين القطريين عن تقدير واشنطن
للشراكه طويله الامد بين البلدين واضافه
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير سيؤكد على
دور الدوحه ومساهمتها المهمه في
الدبلوماسيه الرياضيه الدوليه باستضافتها
لكاس العالم وسيحضر وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه المباراه التي افتتاحيه للمنتخب
الامريكي في كاس العالم لكره القدم امام
ويلز
هذا قد قلت لولوه الخاطر مساعدته وزير
الخارجيه القطريه في مؤتمر الصحفي بالدوحه
ان دوله قطر ومن خلال مبادره فيفا قطر
2022 للجميع اقامت مناطق للمشجعين خاصه
للنازحين واللاجئين في عدد من الدول منها
فلسطين والاردن والعراق واليمن والسودان
فعاله لتلق الشعوب وتعزيز السلامي والحوار
والمصالحه ان حرصنا على اقامه مناطق
المشجعين يترجموا ايماننا راسخ بقدره
الرياضه على احداث تغيير اجتماعيا ايجابي
يحفزوا التنميه المستدامه لا سيما من خلال
التسامح والاحترام والتمكين المجتمعات
اصبحت بطوله كاس العالم في قطر على مسافه
يوم وساعات بعد ان كانت على بعد 12 سنه
كانت المدى الزمني الذي شهد اكبر تجربه
تنمويه في قطر هذه التجربه لم تقتصر فقط
على بناء الملاعب الرياضيه شملت كذلك بناء
وتاسيس دوله عصريه ويرى القطريون ان هذه
البطوله جمله باهره في متن في متن المنجز
الوطني رغم حملات التشكيك والتشويه كاس
العالم في قطر يمثلوا كسرا للمركزيه
الكرويه والعله يغري بكسر مركزيات اخرى في
الثقافه والسياسه والقيم تقرير فوز بشرى
كانه ما يداني مرفوعتان الى السماء
ضلعتان حامدتان شاكرتان
الانعام والالاء فقر تكتب قصيدتها ليس على
الورق بل على الارض عمرانا ما كان ذلك
صدفه فالصفه لا تصنع وطنه بل هي خطه طموحه
خرجت من السطور اذ كانت حلما في مصطلح على
تسميته رؤيه قطر 2030
فاذا رايت ثم رايت حديثه في ترتيب الحياه
وصناعه الجمال وتطورا ياخذ بكل منشط مما
راشقها فتلك هي تجليات الرؤيا الرؤيه التي
حرصت على تحقيق اعلى درجات الحداثه دون ان
تغفل عن الامساك بيد التقاليد والتراث
فلا ينفصل الطالب
فاذا رايت ثم رايت تطورا في جميع اوجه
الحياه ما خلا منها وجه فانما هي الخطه
تخرجها من الورق اراده جعلت شعارها قطر
تستحق الافضل اما الهدف الذي نصت عليه
الخطه التي صدرت بموجب قرار اميري في
العام 2008 فهو تحقيق التقدم والازدهار
بحيث تتحول قطر الى دوله متقدمه قادره على
تحقيق التنميه المستدامه التي تؤمن العيش
الكريمه لشعبها جيلا بعد جيل
الصدفه لا تستطيع وطنه
اعلان فوز قطر في عام 2010 بتنظيم كاس
العالم للعام 22 كان استراحا لفعل يقع
خارج المتخيل خارج المتوقع فقد اخلد الدول
العالم غير المتنفذه الى المقاعد التي
خصصها لها ما يسمى العالم الاول
كانت الدفع بملف قطر اصاله عن نفسها
ونيابه عن منطقه العربيه وما وراء المنطقه
العربيه فعلا سر به خلق واغاظ من اغاض
سيؤثر ظفر قطر بتنظيم كاس العالم لكره
القدم البطوله التي ينشد الى متابعه
فعالياتها الاف الملايين من البشر في
مختلف ارجاء الارض
سيمثل دفعا قويا لخطه التنميه الطموحه
سيتحول التحدي امام قطر الى ملحمه وطنيه
كبرى حتى لا تبدو في سنواتها العشر
الاخيره البقعه الاكثر نشاطا وتشيدا على
مستوى العالم اليوم صار مكان مستحيلا
ممكنه
الاجماع من لدن الفيفا الى اخر مشجع بكره
القدم على ان بطوله قطر ستكون الاكثر
تميزا من بين جميع بطولات كاس العالم
فكل شيء يتصل بالبطوله تم اعداده ليس فقط
ليخدم وظيفته وغرضه بل يجب ان يكون ايه في
الجمال
الملاعب التي اعدت المباريات مثل التحف
المعماريه وقيما انسانيه ووفاء للتراث
ولثقافه المكان وقد تمثل تجريبا معماريا
فانتازيا مثل استاد تسعه سبعه اربعه الذي
صمم ونفذ بحاويات البضائع ليمثله رقم
الاتصال الدولي لقطر
سيكتشف العالم ان قطر ليست فقط كاس العالم
بل هي جائزه قطاره لروايه العربيه الجائزه
الارفع في مجالها
وسيكتشف ان قطر ليست الغاز فقط بل هي
جائزه الشيخ حمد للترجمه والتفاهم الدولي
الاعلى قيمه في مجال ترجمه عيون المعارف
الانسانيه العالميه الى العربيه
سته شهور القادم الى قطر ان مؤسسه قطر
التعليميه تحتضن افضل الجامعات الغربيه
بجانب الجامعات الوطنيه وان المكتبه
الوطنيه هي الاحدث بين المكتبات والاضخم
عدد كتب في منطقه العربيه
كاس العالم سيجلي قطر للناس سواء
بالمشاهده عيانا او بالمتابعه عبر شاشات
التلفزيون على مدى نحو شهر والذين يشاهدون
في مختلف انحاء العالم ستكون عينهم بي ان
سبورت الشبكه الرياضيه الاكبر في دول جنوب
الكره الارضيه
كثير مما صنعت قطر في مشروع تاسيس الدوله
الحديثه مظهرا ومخبرا ما كان ليظهر بهذا
الجلاء لولا كاس العالم
وهو بمثابه الجائزه الكبرى
لمشروعي رؤيه قطر
اما اذا تاملت فيما وراء اياد كره القدم
فستجد كثيرا من الحذر الكلامي والثقافي
والاجتماعي الذي من شانه مركزيه سياسيه
وثقافيه وقيميه لا تكاد ترى في الخصوصيات
الثقافيه للمجتمعات الاخرى الا مفارقه
لسويتها الاخلاقيه
ولسدادها المؤبد قصتك كاس العالم في قطر
تفتح باب لطال ما ظل مغلقه وهو ان العالم
اوسع من يحشر سكانه في قالب قيمي ثقافي
واحد وان فكره الهوامش المغبونه والمكرسه
سوقه استهلاكيه والمسجوله في خانه
المشاهده هي مما يزكي حجاج المحاجين
بضروره تعدد اخطاب العالم
بطوله كاس العالم في قطر خطوه واسعه في
ذلك الطريق اما الذين اساءهم تنظيم قطر
كاس العالم
واطلقوا عليها حملات التشكيك والتشويه
فلعل الدوله المضيفه
تتعذى بقول نبيل عربي قديم فان اكل لحمه
وفرت لحومهم وان هدموا مجدي بنيت لهم مجده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
خاصه لمتابعه التحقيقات المتعلقه بالرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب في قضيتي وثائق البيت
الابيض السريه ومساعي على قله التصديق على
النتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
انكورين
على التطورات الاخيره
للرئاسه في الانتخابات المقبله وكذا اعلان
الرئيس الحالي نيته للترشح خلصت الى ان
المصلحه العامه تقتضي تعيين محقق خاص
تعيينه يؤكد التزام الوزاره بالاستقلاليه
والمساءله في قضايا حساسه بشكل خاص كما
يسمح هذا التعيين للمدعين العامين بمواصله
عملهم على وجه السرعه واتخاذ قرارات تعتمد
على الوقائع والقانون فقط
باشك هانسو ومعنى من واشنطن مراسلنا محمد
الاحمد اهلا وسهلا بك محمد ما الذي تعنيه
بالضبط هذه الخطوه
هذا هذه الخطوه محمد تهدف الى ااا اعطاء
انطباع من طرف وزاره العدل الامريكيه ان
هناك استقلاليه في عملها بعد تعيينها
لمحقق خاص للنظر في قضيتين في ديراليتين
تجريهما وزاره العدل الامريكيه القضيه
الاولى فهم جوانب تتعلق باحداث السادس من
يناير لاسيا اي محاولات تدخل غير قانونيه
بشان عمليه نقل السلطه عقب انتخابات 2020
والقضيه الثانيه تهم تعامل الرئيس السابق
دون ترامب مع ملف الوثائق السريه وزير
العدل الامريكي ميري جارد قال انه هناك
مصلحه عامه في تعيين مده اي او محقق خاص
خاصه في ظل التطورات الاخيره حيث اشار الى
اعلان الرئيس السابق دون ترامب عن ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه مجددا وايضا
نيه الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن في الترشح
مجددا وزير العدل قال ان هذا القرار يعكس
التزام الوزاره بالاستقلاليه والمحاسبه في
هذين
قضيتين طبعا ايضا وزير العدل الامريكي
اشار الى ان المحقق القاسي جاكس سميث لن
يكون خاضعا او تابعا لاي مسؤول في وزاره
العدل لكنه في نفس الوقت
يتبع ارشادات واحكام واجراءات وزاره العدل
الامريكيه طبعا هذه الخطوه محمد في هذا
السياق خاصه بعد ثلاثه ايام من اعلان
الرئيس السابق دون ترامب عن الترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه مجددا هو في الحقيقه
يهدف ل- همم لوضع محقق خاص للاشراف على
هذين القضيتين الفيدراليتين همم بحيث تسعى
وزاره العدل للنائي بنفسها عن اي تضارب
للمص او وصف
لتحقيقاتها بانها مسيسه طبعا لحد الان لا
يوجد رد فعل من الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب لكنه طالما وسط التحقيقات التي
تطاله بانها تنطوي على يعني شبهات او
اهداف سياسيه طبعا هو مده اي فيدرالي له
خبره طويله همم شغل قسم النزاه في وزاره
العدل ومنذ عام 2018 يشغل مدعي عام رفيع
الاداء المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بشان
جرائم الحرب طبعا هذه قضيه متفاعله في
الاوساط السياسيه الاجنبيه السؤال كيف
ستؤثر على مسار دونالد ترامب السياسي خاصه
بعد ترشحه للانتخابات في 2020 محمد شكرا
لكم محمد الاحمد واشنطن
[موسيقى]
تويتر تغلقوا مكاتبها بصوره مؤقته ولي
بضعه ايام السبب رفض الموظفين للعمل
واستقاله مئات منهم اعتراض على توجهات
المالك الجديد للمنصه الملياردير الى
المسجد
سارعه
ومتواليه
قالت واشنطن بوست ان موقع تويتر في وضع
حرج وسط تساؤلات حول قدرته على الاستمرار
في العمل
ما الذي يجري في تويتر عملاق التواصل
الاجتماعيه والخدمات الاخباريه والاعلاميه
وغيرها اعلان مفاجئون باغلاق جميع مكاتب
الشركه حتى الاثنين المقبل بعد رفض الاف
الموظفين مواصله العمل بموجب رؤيه ماسك
المعلنه وتقديم استقالاتهم وكانت الاداره
الجديده للموقع قد طلبت من الموظفين
الدخول الى رابط لتاكيد الالتزامهم بما
سمي بتويتر الجديده والا فثمه ما ينتظرهم
اي خساره وظائف فيهم تلقائيا والحصول على
راتب ثلاثه اشهر تعويضا عن نهايه الخدمه
الازمات تعصف بتويتر منذ ان استحوذ ماسك
رسميا على الموقع وقيامه بطرد كبار
المسؤولين في خطوه اثارت جدلا كبيره
16 عاما شكل فيها تويتر فضاءا عاما للناس
وان كان رقميا جمع العالم بقراته الخمس في
خط زمنيا تستعرض عليه تغريدات فكان اداه
رئيسيه للناشطين في العالم للحشد والتعبئه
والتشبيك والضغط والتنظيم وقبل ذلك كله
كان اداه تخترق التعتيم الاعلاميه
التقليدي فلم يعوده هناك ما يمكن اخفاءه
او صوت يمكن كتمه اذا كيف تحولت واحده من
اهم منصات الرقميه المزوده للاخبار الى
ماده دسمه للاخبار وبشكل متسارع فبعد ايام
قليله من الاستغناء عن نصف موظفي
مبدا العمل من المنزل وفرض ساعات عمل
طويله كل هذا في سبيل ما يسميه
نيته الخاصه لاصلاح من الصعب دعك من خططه
لفرد رسوم اشتراك شهريه على خدمات اضافيه
بما فيها التوثيق ليقضي على مصداقيه
الحسابات الموثوقه ويغرق الموقع في فوض
الحسابات الوهميه تاثرت منصه بهذه
التطورات فاغلاق المكاتب ومنع العمل من
المنزل الثرى بصوره او باخرى على العمليات
والدعم الفني مما جعل الموقع يواجه مشاكل
فنيه بحسب موقع الداوندكتور منذ تاسيسها
عام 2006 نحت تويتر منحنى اكثر انضباطا
فيما يتعلق بحجم التغريدات بعيدا عن الحشو
الزائد لكن الاهم من ذلك ان تويتر تحولت
الى مصدر موثوق للاخبار خاصه من طرف
الحسابات الموثقه والرسميه الى جانب اقبال
كثير من الزعماء والسياسيين وقاده الراي
والنخاب والمشاهير وغيرهم عليها لكن يبدو
ان كل هذا في طريقه نحو النسيان
الرجل الاغنى في العالم لن يتوقف بتويتر
عند هذا الحد ففي احداث تغريداته قال فكر
فيها مليا في اشاره الى المغسله التي دخل
بها اول يوم الى المقر الرئيسي للموقع في
اشاره الرمزيه لتنظيف الموقع
[موسيقى]
في غزه شويه اليوم واحد وعشرون جثمانا هم
ضحايا فاجعه هزتنا جميعا حريق التهم
منزلهم لا يمكن عدم الربط بين الحادث
الاليم والحصار الخانقي على القطاع منذ
2006 حربان الفلسطينيين في غزه من
الكهرباء وتعذر ارسال المعدات الضروريه
لجهاز الدفاع المدني في النهايه بندر
البعض الارتفاع عدد الضحايا سياسه العقاب
الجماعيه التي فرضها الاحتلال ادت الى
تدهور في الوضع الانساني وتردد في الخدمات
الاساسيه بشكل قاتل ينقطع التيار
الكهربائي في غزه ما بين اثنتا عشر ساعه
و20 ساعه في اليوم الواحد
يدفع الكثيره من العائلات الى تخزين
الوقود واعتماده بعض البدائل الرخيصه لعمل
المولدات الخاصه ما يعرض العائلات بمخاطر
عديده
الدفاع المدني منذ 2007 لم يتمكن من
استيراد اي معدات او مركبات مخصصه لعمله
فالجهاز يفتقر الى اليات ثقيله ومركبات
اطفاء وانقاذ واسعاف مجهزه بكامل المعدات
الضروريه واللازمه كما تنقصه بسبب الحصار
خراطيم المياه الخاصه باخماد الحرائق
ومولدات الكهرباء سنوات الحصار الطويله
ادت الى ترد القطاع الصحي في غزه تجاوزت
نسبه تراجع الخدمات خدمات الرعايه الصحيه
66%
غزه الخانق فردته سلطات الاحتلال بطريقه
معاقبه حركه حماس بعد فوزها في الانتخابات
التشريعيه عام 2006 ثم عززت اسرائيل
الحصار في 2007 بعد سيطره حماس على غزه في
حزيران من العام نفسه
في دخول المحروقات والكهرباء والكثير من
السلع الاساسيه ومنع الصيد في عمق البحر
واغلاق المعابر بين القطاع واسرائيل
تل ابيب وبعد حادثه الاعتداء على اسطول
الحريه الذي كان يستهدف كسر الحصار كما
اعلن الناشطون على مثله خففت الحظر
المفروضه على دخول بعض السلع الغذائيه
ودوات المطبخ ولعب الاطفال بينما رفضت
حركه حماس القراره واعتبرته دعائيا وغير
عمله
الحاله المترديه لسكان القطاع دفعت منسق
الشؤون الانسانيه في الامم المتحده
ماكسويل جيلر الى وصف الحصار بانه ابتداء
على الكرامه الانسانيه
للمزيد ينضم الينا منكم محمد شحاده مسؤول
البرامج والاتصال في المرصد الاورو
المتوسطي لحقوق الانسان اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
شحاته
ما جرى في غزه هل يمكن ان يحرك الملف
الانساني
المتفاقم والمزمن هناك
هي بصراحه
او ماساه جمه متعدده الاوجه وجميع اسباب
هذا هذه النتيجه الكارثيه تشير الى حصار
اسرائيل المستمر منذ عام 2006 لدينا هنا
اشكاليه في ال ال الكثافه السكانيه
العاليه خاصه في مخيمات اللاجئين تتبعها
المشكل التي ذكرتها انهيار قطاعات باكملها
نتيجه للاحصار الاسرائيلي المستمر وايضا
فيما يتعلق بالدفاع المدني في قطاع غزه
حيث تم
استهلاك او انتهاك هذا القطاع بشكل يعني
جنوني فعلى سبيل المثال خلال سنوات الحصار
الماضيه منذ العام 2006 حتى الان لم تسمح
اسرائيل بادخال اي مركبات لقطاع الدفاع
المدني سوى مركبه واحده
واضف الى ذلك ان اسرائيل قامت بقصف اكثر
من 18 منشاه تابعه للدفاع المدني في غزه
كما وقامت بالحاق الاضرار وتدمي اكثر من
31 مركبه كليا او جزئيا كما قتل على يد
الهجمات الاسرائيليه نحو 25 من طاقه من
الدفاع المدني في قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى
حالات كثيره من الجرحى فهذه كلها ادت الى
تركيبه كارثيه فاقمت من هذه الحادثه
وجعلتها بالحجم الذي رايناه للاسف البارحه
هذه التركيبه الكارثيه كما كما وصفتها هل
هناك نوع من التراخي الدولي الانسان في
التعامل معها في فتره الماضيه
هو للاسف الاسرائيل تحاول اقناع المجتمع
الدولي بان الوضع الراهن
الكارثي في قطاع غزه بامكاننا المماطله
فيه مدى الحياه بامكاني ان يستمر على ما
هو الى ما لا نهايه وهناك حاله من الاذعان
من المجتمع الدولي مع هذه الحاله او تناسي
قطاع غزه في الاوقات التي لا يحدث فيها
عنف بالمعنى
[موسيقى]
المعنى الصريح او العنف الدموي سوى ذلك
عندما لا يكون هناك قصف على غزه او تصعيد
عسكري يتم اهمالها وتماثيها بشكل شبه كامل
من المجتمع الدولي اذعانا للسياسه
الاسرائيليه التي تدعي بان هذا الوضع
القابل الغير قابل للسيطره وهذا الوضع
المدمر للشعب من 2 مليون نسمه من المدنيين
يمكن الاستمرار به الى ما لا نهايه
هل الانصراف المجتمع الدولي الى الاهتمام
بما يجري في اوكرانيا اهم شيء الى حد ما
هذه الملفات التي تشير اليها
بالطبع يعني في السنوات الاخيره وخاصه في
هذا العام في ظل اداره تم يسمى بتجميد
القضيه الفلسطينيه نضعها في الديب فريزر
وبتناثر وجودها ونتناسى حل الصراع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني بشكل كامل ونلتفت
لما يسمى بهم من ملفات اكثر اهميه فللاسف
لم تعد القضيه الفلسطينيه على الاجندات
الدوليه سواء في اوروبا او في امريكا كما
كانت في السابق بل يتم تنسيها
والاحتجاج بانه بامكاننا تقليص الصراع او
احتوائه وليس معالجته وبذلك يتم تناسي
اثنين مليون نسمه في قطاع غزه يعيشون فيما
وصفه المقرر او المفوض العام لحقوق
الانسان السابق زيد بن رعد بانه همم
بالوعه من او كسجن
باوضاع تؤدي الى تسمم سكانها او كما قال
بالانجليزيه
يعني منطقه كثيفه السكان تؤدي الى تسمين
بطيء لسكان هذا القطاع في ظل الاذعان
والتجاهل من المجتمع الدولي وكما وصفته
الدكتوره ساره الرويوي من جامعه هاربورد
وقالت ان ما يحدث في غزه هو تصميم بطيء
اثنين مليون شخص يجبر فيه الاهالي على
مشاهده اطفالهم وهم يتناولون المياه
الملوثه بشكل يومي ويتناولون الطعام الذي
زرع بمياه ملوثه بما يؤدي للموت البطيء من
دون اي نهايه او حل في هذا المجال شكرا
محمد من لبنان
[موسيقى]
فعلا الفجر